welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
Jacobo court hearing is underway right
now in Puerto Rico for the grandfather
of a toddler who died after falling from
a cruise-ship window you may remember
this story Salvatore anello is charged
with negligent homicide in the death was
18 month old granddaughter
Chloe Wiegand the little girl fell more
than a hundred feet back in July when
anello lifted her up to a window while
the ship was docked in San Juan the
family's attorney says a nello thought
the window was closed but was actually
open our lead national correspondent
David Beck know is at the courthouse in
San Juan David this hearing got underway
just minutes ago what can we expect
we're expecting Anthony that a trial
date will be set the grandfather is
expected to be here in court listen this
is an this is a story that is really
ripping the people here in Puerto Rico
and I have to tell you just from reading
social media in the story being posted
online a lot of people are surprised and
object to the fact that the prosecutors
filed charges here against the
grandfather because many Puerto Ricans
believe the grandfather is going to
suffer enough living the rest of his
life knowing that he arguably was in
some way responsible for what happened
in the girl what's interesting here is
that we haven't seen any evidence in
this case that alleges or proves that
the grandfather was negligent but there
is surveillance video and as of now that
video
more than four and a half months after
Chloe Wiegand fell to her death aboard
this Royal Caribbean cruise ship the
little girl's family is shocked that
Puerto Rican prosecutors are holding her
grandfather Salvatore anello responsible
the family's really not doing well I
think they're really devastated by the
fact that these charges have been filed
and that this case continues to go
forward what are they shocked by they're
shocked because they think it's
groundless they certainly didn't want
charges to be filed Michel Winkelman is
the family's attorney he is not
representing the grandfather in the
criminal case he says despite the wishes
of the family Puerto Rican prosecutors
are pushing forward the reason
Winckelmann says the accident as he
calls it was caught on surveillance
camera and although he thinks the
grandfather is not criminally
responsible the prosecutors may be
seeing something else you have to assume
that it shows something that really led
the Puerto Rican authorities to believe
that there was a criminal offense so
clearly there's something in that video
that video has not been released by
prosecutors who accused the grandfather
of negligence saying his behavior caused
the 18 month-old to fall nearly 150 feet
to a concrete deck below and for that
reason Chloe's family points the finger
at Royal Caribbean accusing the cruise
liner of creating a fatal safety hazard
and now they're planning to sue
Winckelmann says the little girl's
grandfather he believes has already been
punished enough I think this was a
tragic mistake it will haunt them
forever and there's just really no
reason for charges to have been filed
the cruise line issued a very stormy
short statement saying because they
expect a lawsuit to be filed they have
no comment they believe what happened to
the little girl was a tragic accident
Anthony we're going to find out today
whether or not that surveillance video
is going to be released to the pub
everything about this case is
heartbreaking David beg no and Puerto
Rico Thanks you know I mean everything
when David said they're the people of
Puerto Rico their hearts are breaking
everybody that hears who stirs everybody
yeah I mean as a parent is a double
killing yeah